factorizar 8 k cuadrada menos 24 k menos
144 y bueno lo primero que me gustaría
que vieras es que todo esto es divisible
entre 8 8 entre 8 es 124 entre 8 edad 3
y menos 144 a poco se puede dividir
entre 8 y que salga exacto pues vamos a
hacerlo aquí arriba para ver si 144 si
es divisible entre 8 obteniendo un
resultado entero así que vamos a ver 8
entre 144 y dice 8 cabe una vez el 14
entonces le vamos a quitar a 14 8 menos
8 me quedan 6 bajo el 4 y me queda 64 y
64 cabe 8 veces en 8 por lo tanto 144 si
es divisible entre 8 y nos da 18 así que
voy a factorizar primeramente un 8 voy a
factorizar el 8 como factor común y me
va a quedar lo siguiente 8 que
multiplica a cuadrada después me va a
quedar 24 entre 8 me da menos 3 camps y
menos 144 entre 8 me da menos 18 por lo
tanto ya tengo mi factor común el primer
factor es
ahora me voy a fijar en esta expresión
que tengo aquí está cuadrada menos 3 k
menos 18 y lo que voy a buscar es algo
de la forma x cuadrada más bx más donde
el número que está al lado del ex
cuadrada es uno y por lo tanto siempre
me pregunto dos números que sumados me
den b y dos números que multiplicados me
den dos números que sumados me deben el
término que este lado de la x que por
cierto en este caso es menos 3 es el
término que este lado de la cama y esos
mismos dos números multiplicados me
tienen que darse en este caso es menos
18 que es el término libre así que vamos
a pensar dos números que multiplicados
me den menos 18 y que sumados me den
menos 3 lo primero que quiero que veas
es que menos 18 tiene el signo negativo
por lo tanto uno tiene que ser positivo
y el otro tiene que ser negativo 18 se
puede factorizar en 118 pero aún así no
queda porque como uno tiene que ser
positivo y no negativo 18 menos uno me
da 17 y si cambiamos los signos me va a
quedar menos 18 más 1 lo cual me da
menos 17
3 - 3 entonces no funciona de estos dos
más menos 1 y menos más 18 no funcionan
estos dos vamos a buscar otros dos se me
ocurre 3 más menos 3 y menos más 6 si te
das cuenta 6 por 3 me da 18
puedo poner uno positivo y uno negativo
y si yo pongo que el 6 sea negativo y el
13 a positivo me dan menos 3 así que ya
quedaron si yo pongo que 3 sea positivo
y 6 sea negativo me va a quedar 3 por 6
menos 18 y menos 6 + 3 me da menos 3
pues el negativo es más grande entonces
puedo escribir este término que está
aquí en medio de la siguiente forma
voy a seguir obteniendo el 8 y en lugar
de poner menos 3 acá voy a poner más 3 k
y menos 6 acá entonces el 8 sigue siendo
factor común aquí voy a poner más 3 506
camps
aquí me queda acá cuadrada y después al
final me queda menos 18 fíjate que más
crezca menos 6 acá es lo mismo que menos
3 camps
he hecho nada y ahora sí puedo utilizar
la factorización por agrupación es decir
no voy a fijar en los dos primeros
términos de esta expresión que tengo
aquí y voy a sacar lo más que pueda de
ellos dos el factor común más grande que
puede obtener de ellos dos y por otra
parte voy a hacer lo mismo con los
últimos dos términos de esta expresión
por lo tanto me queda 8 que multiplica a
mi factor común entre k cuadrada y 3
camps es camps ambos dicen k por lo
tanto voy a poner camps que multiplica a
quien acá en primer lugar más 3 ya que
multiplica acá más 3 y después me va a
quedar más menos 6 si te das cuenta el
factor más grande que tienen entre estos
dos es menos 6 menos 6 divide a ambos
términos de este binomio me queda menos
6 que multiplica acá más 3 otra vez y
bueno quiero mejor 7 y en ese momento es
cuando me doy cuenta que acá más 3 es
factor común justo esto es lo que se
hace cuando tenemos una factorización
por agrupación veo que acá más 3 es mi
factor común y por lo tanto lo voy a
sacar en mi siguiente paso multiplicando
a quien sean más 3 van multiplica
en primer lugar a camps y en segundo
lugar a menos seis más por menos me da
menos y me quedaría acá menos seis camas
tres que multiplica acá en primer lugar
y después a menos 6 en segundo lugar y
aquí ya obtuve la factorización completa
de esta expresión que tengo aquí esto es
lo mismo que 8 que multiplica acá más 3
porque a menos 6 justo estos son los
pasos que utilizamos cuando factor
izamos por agrupación y perfecto ya lo
hicimos y de hecho puedo quitar los
broches después el orden de los factores
de afecto el producto y no me voy a
complicar más con corchetes esto es lo
mismo que poner 8 que multiplica acá más
3 que a su vez multiplica acá menos 6 y
ya obtuve la factorización que me
estaban pidiendo en este ejercicio